tour celebrate the holidays with a
wonderful winter display
take a look it's grand it's festive
hopeful holidays debuted at the bellagio
conservatory in botanical gardens today
rocky theater spoke to the designer
we've been hanging here at the bellagio
conservatory and botanical gardens where
of course there is a new display for the
season this one
happy and hopeful holidays right ed
absolutely it's a happy hopeful holiday
here at the bellagio
and you design this place every season
and it's seriously just incredible
talent just tell us the stories that are
behind
these displays i do and you know what we
really wanted to do
for this season is to invite everybody
down and to celebrate
with us the fact that there's going to
be a hopeful and happy new year and a
healthy new year so
in the in the north bed we have this
beautiful visitation from a cardinal
which represents kind of like a message
from heaven that things are going to be
okay
in an egg which represents rebirth so
we're kind of like refreshing it all and
and just doing a happy healthy holiday
for everybody yes and then down there i
see something really elaborate can you
can you break down that story for us so
that's actually one of my favorite beds
the south that
is it started off as the idea of an elf
little situation
and then we decided that we were going
to show the inside of the queen's castle
so that's what it that's where we got
and the next step with that
is as we started like pinpointing who
the elves were going to be
we we basically we created a situation
where the whole bed represents the team
that puts this together
so it's the designers the electricians
the florists the gardeners
the people who feed the fish and put up
the lights does everybody here is
represented and in this
year more than any other the camaraderie
of this team that pulling off the show
for the public is really what we wanted
to kind of get across i can imagine that
and like you said it instead of the
typical elves and santa claus display
you guys are representing your team
that's beautiful and it's
and there's a puppy wrong with puppy and
you're speaking of team i want to bring
in leslie here who's with the bellagio
just invite people down who are whether
they're local whether they're
a tourist i'd love that both are welcome
yes we
are keeping traditions alive no matter
what here
at bellagio in the conservatory so we're
looking forward to welcoming people
and we have our social distancing in
place which really elevates the
experience we have a lot of
instagramable moments
places to take photos and maybe even
make your christmas card out of those
photos that's a great idea obviously
this is for families it's a great date
night or during the day because at night
time it becomes it becomes alive as well
yeah i mean one of the
great things about the way that we
design this is that it takes on a
completely different atmosphere in the
evening
so it's really important for people to
come down and see it during the day and
then come back at night as well
all right well i will send it back to
you guys come down through january 9th
to visit the bellagio happy hopeful
holidays
ah such a beautiful place love to go
there when it always changes for the
season
we want to see your holiday displays as
well how